i'll tell you what i learned from how
seal team six hicks from the navy seals
to make seal team six and how i used
that same structure to pick who i wanted
to work in my company so in seal team
six they said it's baseline it's ticket
of entry that you'd give your life for
another guy in the team but to get to
seal team six you have to have even
stronger and deeper character and what
they look at is would i be able to trust
my wife with this person if i left for
months at a time they would be absolute
men of honor to the same degree could i
trust this person with a big pile of
money far more than they had i could
give it to them and i could say hey i'll
be back sometime come back one month one
year 10 years later and it would still
be there as we're looking at new
candidates we're asking not only do i
think this person is good character but
we test that character under different
situations to see what's inside if it
would come out and that's how we see
this is the type person that i want to
work at my company and represent me